COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS. AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN CAPITAL ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE WITH NONE OF
OUR MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE WITH ME TODAY ARE
SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY GLAZER
MCGUIRE MITCHELL BOTH AND PAN.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC S. ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. PRETTY
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL REMOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO TELL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
THERE CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE AN MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID TO STICK FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THIS
HEARING HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE. REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT ALL HEARINGS. IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS OR JUSTIN
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN THE HEARING NOW WE HAVE
TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
SOME BILLS ON CONSENT. THE BILL
ON CONSENT OUR ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB THREE OH NINE. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB THREE TWENTY.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB FOUR TWENTY
ONE ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
FORTY SIX ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
FIVE SIXTEEN. ITEM ELEVEN AB
NINE SEP FOURTEEN ITEM TWELVE
AB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION OF BILLS WAS
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BETTER
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR LEYVA. LEAVE HERE.
BOTH A TROUBLE CARE KERR. YOUR
CORTES A HAIR DALY. DELHI
GLAZER. GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE.
PAN YEAH PAN HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM MEMBERS ARE WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE UP THE CAN CALENDAR AT
THIS TIME DO WE HAVE A MOTION
SENATOR DOLLY MA'AM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSENT
SENATOR LEYVA ALL RIGHT LEYVA
HI- CHILUBA- TOLD AYE CORTESE
AYE COURTESY AYE DALLI. DALLI
HI GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
PAN. PAN I BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR APPS MEMBER ALL RIGHT
LET'S START WITH OUR FIRST BILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TASHA-
BARNBURNER. BEING TOUGH YOU
KNOW YOU SHOULD DO A BETTER JOB
ON YOUR NAME BURNER. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY WITH
AB SIXTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
SIXTY SIX WILL PROVIDE SCRIPT
INSTITUTION OF OCEANOGRAPHY
WITH STATE FUNDING FOR RESEARCH
SHOW FORM THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
BLUFF COLLAPSED EARLY WARNING
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM. TO IMPROVE
BEACH SAFETY AND PREVENT
FURTHER FATALITIES. UP WITHOUT
A GLOVE FAILURES HAVE CAUSED
HUMAN INJURY AND SEVERAL DEATHS
IN RECENT YEARS. ON JULY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A WOMAN DIED AFTER
SHE FELL HUNDRED FIFTY FEET
FROM A SEASIDE BLUFF IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY WHEN THE GROUND
BENEATH HER CRUMBLED THE CLIFF
IN BATTERED BY WINTER STORMS
AND COLLAPSED. ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN SAN FRANCISCO A
WOMAN A DOG WERE RESCUED
ANOTHER WOMAN REMAIN TRAPPED
AFTER THE EDGE OF A CLIFF
COLLAPSED ON TOP OF THEM
BEARING ONE VICTIM UNDER TONS
OF DIRT. THE TRUMP WOMAN'S BODY
WAS NEVER RECOVERED. AUGUST
TWENTY NINETEEN IN MY OWN
DISTRICT DOWN THE STREET FROM
ME THREE PEOPLE WERE FATALLY
CRUSHED WHEN A BLUFF COLLAPSED
IN CITIES BEACH IN MY HOMETOWN
THE VICTIMS ARE PART OF A LARGE
FAMILY GATHERING THAT DAY. AND
HOW THE BLUFF COLLAPSE A FEW
SECONDS EARLIER. THE DEATH TOLL
WOULD HAVE INCLUDED CHILDREN.
AND ADDITION TO PUBLIC CAN.
ERODING CLIFFS THREATENED
EXTENSIVE CLIFFTOP DEVELOPMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
HIGHWAYS RAILWAYS. WELL WASTE
WATER OIL NATURAL GAS AND
NUCLEAR FACILITIES UNIVERSITY
SEVERAL CRITICAL MILITARY
BASES. AND NO MORE STATE PARKS
AND BEACHES. RECENT BLOOD
FAILURES IN THE CITY OF DEL MAR
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY THREATEN
THE LOS AND QUARTER REAL. THE
REAL WAY THAT HAVE RESULTED IN
MULTIPLE CLOSURES OF THE SECOND
BUSIEST RECORDER IN THE COUNTRY
IMPACTING COMMUTERS FOR
TRANSPORT AND THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO AND THE STATE'S EONOMY.
WHAT IS MISSING RIGHT NOW AS
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF SCIENCE
ARAMBULA FAILURES I UNDERSTAND
THE PROCESS THAT DRIVES BLOOD
FOR YOU YEARS NOT A LONG TERM
PROCESS BUT THE IMMEDIATE WHEN
CAN WE PREDICT WHEN THEY'RE
GOING TO HAPPEN. BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE AT THE BLEAK BEACH AND
YOU'RE STANDING IN FRONT OF US
IN ITS TEN SECONDS TO RUN INTO
THE OCEAN YOU NEED SO LITTLE
TIME AND WE'VE DONE THIS WITH
EARTHQUAKES NOW I WANT TO DO
THIS WITH MY FINGERS- WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THE- IN THE CAR.
IS FOR CO MANAGER AND BUILDING
RES. AND SAFE COMMUNITY. AS YOU
KNOW MEMBERS THE LEGISLATOR ALL
KIDS FUNDING FOR SEVERAL
RESEARCH PROGRAMS WITH THE UC.
RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES AND THIS
IS WHAT THE REASON THAT WHY
THIS BILLS BEFORE YOU TO THIS
MORNING FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. TESTIFYING FOR THE BILL
TODAY OF MARXISM BURKE. HE'S A
RESEARCH GEOPHYSICIST FROM
INSTITUTE OF GEOPHYSICS AND
PLANETARY PHYSICS AT SCRIPTS.
YOU CAN ASK THEM LOTS OF
QUESTIONS VERY FAST ME AND TALK
WITH HIM. AND HIS- HERE TO.
MAKE A STATEMENT AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. BUT THE
ACTUAL PRODUCT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO OUR
LEAD SUPPORT MISTER SOME BURKE-
MET MR MODERATOR OR MODERATOR.
IS HE ON THE LINE. I AM ON LINE.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU SURE LEYVA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANKS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL WE THINK
IT CAN SIGNIFICANTLY ADVANCE
RESEARCH ON THE DYNAMICS OF
CLIFF COLLAPSE ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COAST LINES. MY
COLLEAGUES GROUPS DR ADAM YOUNG
WILL FUNDING FROM THE STATE
PARKS OCEANOGRAPHY PROGRAM. HAS
BEEN SERVING THE CLIFFS BETWEEN
SAN DIEGO ON CEAN SIDE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS USING LIDAR LIDAR
IS THE SYSTEM THAT SCANS THE
CLIFFS WITH THE LASER. CREATING
A HIGHLY DETAILED SPATIAL MAPS
WITH RESOLUTION MEASURED IN
INCHES. THIS LETS US LEARN
WHERE AND HOW OFTEN CLIP
FAILURES OCCUR. DETECTING THE
SMALL HARDLY NOTICEABLE ROCK
FALLS ALL THE WAY TO THE MAJOR
COLLAPSES WHICH THREATEN LIVES
AND PROPERTY. WELL CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINES. WITH FUNDING FROM
THIS BILL WE WOULD AIM TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PROCESSES LEADING UP THE CLIFF
FAILURES. BY DOING TWO THINGS
FIRST WE WILL ACCELERATE THE
COLLECTION OF THE SLIDE ARDAYDA.
ALLOWING FOR MORE FREQUENT AND
BETTER RESOLUTION SCANS OF THE
CLIPS AND THEN ASSIMILATE THESE
MEASUREMENTS INTO A GROWING
HISTORICAL DATABASE TO LEARN
WHERE AND WHEN FAILURES HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE PAST AND WHERE
THEY ARE MOST LIKELY TO OCCUR
IN THE FUTURE. NO KEY GOAL IS
TO FIND OUT IF ANY SIGNATURE
EXISTS THAT COULD FORETELL OF
HEIGHTENED RISK IN SPECIFIC
LOCATIONS. SECONDLY WE WOULD
INSTRUMENT KEY SITES WITH
GEOTECHNICAL MONITORING
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPED CHURCH
GROUPS IN THE PAST FEW YEARS.
THAT CAN DETECT INFINITESIMAL
THE FORMATIONS OF THE ROCKS.
THESE ARE TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE UNTIL THE PAST FEW
YEARS. AGAIN OUR GOAL IS TO
LEARN HOW THE FORMATIONS ARE
IMPACTED BY TIDES LARGE SERVE
GROUNDWATER AND RAINFALL TO SEE
IF WE CAN ANSWER THIS QUESTION
OF WHETHER SIGNALS EXIST THAT
CAN FORECAST WHERE AND WHEN. AN
INCREASED RISK FOR COLLAPSE IS
DEVELOPING. THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU MISTER
SAMBERG WE WILL NOW GO TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE FOR ANYONE
IN SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE HERE
WE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEN NO ONE. ALL RIGHT WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
FORTY TWO OH THREE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE. GOING
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO
ONE AT ALL YOU KNOW WHAT I
PRESS OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT ON NINE SORRY ABOUT
THAT. MISTER HAN OF CAFFEINE
THIS MORNING OKAY SO LET'S
FIRST SO WE'VE CHECKED ALL OF
OUR ROOMS AND NO ONE IS HERE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SIXTY SIX FIRST.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THOSE WHO
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE ENTERED
THIS TIME. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. NOW GO TO LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ENCINITAS OF THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. PINE. TWENTY FOUR. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS MORNING COM ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
CAN YOU SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO'S IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY
SIX ON THE LINE. SKEWS ME AB.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ONE ZERO. THIS IS FOR
THE OPPOSITION ONLY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THERE IS NO
ONE THAT THE SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK EXCELLENT THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR OVER IT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- FIRST OF ALL I
APPRECIATE THE PURPOSES ALL OF
IT MAKE NOTE THAT. DENOUNCES
MENTIONS YOU KNOW. IT IT THE
TERMS OF. BUT FOR THE OTHER
SYSTEMS LIKE- SOMETIMES I THINK
IT'S BEING FRAMED IN A WAY THAT
WERE REQUIRING YOU SEE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT THE- THAT THEY
MAY OR MAY NOT WANT TO DO. AND
THE BUT I THINK MY CONVERSATION
OF THE AUTHOR AND ALSO LOOKING
MORE CAREFULLY AT ANALYSIS- I
THINK REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
DOING IT'S ENABLING. YOU SEE
AND SCRIPTS TO BE ABLE TO DO
AND ACTUALLY HAS OTHER
REQUIREMENTS WHICH I UNDERSTAND
BE HEARD AND OTHER COMMITTEES.
SO WHAT I WOULD NORMALLY BE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT. THUS FAR
NO ALTERNATE AS A FORMER YOU
SEE THAT COMMEMORATIVE
LEGISLATION TELLING YOU SEE YOU
HAVE TO DO A CERTAIN TYPE OF
RESEARCH OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT COULD.
IMPINGE BUT THAT THIS IS NOT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. AND SO- I
DO SO I'M CERTAINLY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND ALSO WOULD
MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
TO HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
EXPECT LAST FOREVER THANK YOU I
WILL MOTION BY SENATOR PAM
MENTAL CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR LEYVA AYE. LEYVA AYE
OCHO. AYE WHICH WILL. A
COURTESY. DELI DELI I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN I AM I.
WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER HAVE A
GREAT DAY. ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO OUR SECOND ITEM WHICH
IS AB TWO FORTY FIVE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. ONCE WE ARE
READY. FOR YOU PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU ARE READY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MORNING MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS- PREACHING YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB TWO FORTY
FIVE. TRANSGENDER NON BINARY
STUDENTS FACE MANY BARRIERS AT
SCHOOL AND IN THE WORKPLACE AND
WE KNOW THAT IF A STUDENT
DOESN'T HAVE AN UPDATED DIPLOMA
OR TRANSCRIPT THEY CAN FACE
CHALLENGES APPLYING FOR
GRADUATE SCHOOL OR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. A COLLEGE
DIPLOMA IS A REPRESENTATION OF
YEARS OF HARD WORK AND ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT WHICH SHOULDN'T%
CAUSE STRESS BY HAVING SOMEONE
THAT NAME ON IT. THE DIPLOMA
THAT HAS THE WRONG NAME ON IT
CAN HAVE THE IMPACT OF OUTING
SOMEONE WHO DOES NOT WISH TO BE
OUTED OR MAY FEEL UNSAFE IN
THEIR CURRENT SITUATION THIS
BILL DOES TWO THINGS IT ALLOWS
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
STUDENTS AT PUBLIC COLLEGES. TO
HAVE THEIR CHOSEN NAME PRINTED
ON THEIR DIPLOMA WHEN THEY
GRADUATE AND SECONDLY IT
CREATES A STANDARD PROCESS FOR
UPDATING STUDENT RECORDS OF
FORMER STUDENTS SO THAT THEIR
NAME AND GENDER ARE ACCURATELY
REFLECTED ON IMPORTANT RECORDS.
THIS BILL THIS BUILDS ON THE AB
SEVEN ELEVEN LAW SIGNED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO MAKE SURE
THAT FORMER K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO UPDATE
THEIR STUDENT RECORDS WE HEARD
FROM COLLEGE STUDENTS FACING
SIMILAR CHARGES AND SO I NEED
TO EXTEND THIS POLICY.
TRANSLITERATE FOLKS FACE LOTS
OF BARRIERS THE NAME OF THE
DIPLOMA SHOULD NOT BE ANOTHER
THING THAT THEY WORRY ABOUT.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR MAIN WITNESS.
ARE JOINED BY TIMMY MARTINTHE
LEGISLATIVE MANAGER FOR
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER. MS MARTIN ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. I AM GOOD
MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ATTENDING MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY AS
A CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY TWO
FORTY FIVE. WHICH IS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED WILL ENSURE THAT
FORMER STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN ACADEMIC RECORDS THAT
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THEIR LEGAL
NAME AND GENDER. REGARDLESS OF
WHEN THEY GRADUATED. IT ALSO
QUITE SPECIFIED SENATE
GRADUATING STUDENT MAY EASILY
HAVE THEIR CHOSEN NAME LISTED
ON THEIR DIPLOMA. WHICH IS THE
CEREMONIAL BUT STILL PERSONALLY
SIGNIFICANT DOCUMENT. AND WHEN
AN ACCURATE INACCURATE DOCUMENT
PUT TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
STUDENTS AT RISK OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HARM. WHEN
THEY USE FOR EXAMPLE A
TRANSCRIPT YOU APPLY FOR JOBS
OR OTHER OPPORTUNITIES. AS THE
AUTHOR HAD MENTIONED AND
THEREBY COMPOUNDING THE VITAL
BARRIERS. TO EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING THAT LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE
ALREADY FACE. DOES NOT
COMMONSENSE BILL IT WILL
ADDRESS INEQUITY THAT WORK
BASED GUARD THE PRIVACY OF ALL
GRADUATES INCLUDING TRANSGENDER
AND NON BINARY RATCHET. AND
ENSURE THE EDUCATIONAL. RECORDS
ARE ACCURATE. RECALL TO A
FAMILY CHIU WHO BEING AND SHE-
FOR THE L. G. B. PLUS COMMUNITY.
OFFERING EIGHTY TWO BY. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR BECAUSE- THAT
WOULD KIND OF GOVERNOR. TO I
WOULD EXPECT WE URGE THE- POINT
THE BILL AS WELL YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MS MARTIN WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL LEAD SUPPORTS WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR TWO ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEEING NO ONE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEE NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. BUT THOSE WHO YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERAPIST
TIME PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I'M SURE WE HAVE THAT
MANY PEOPLE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT AND
WE WILL PROCESS THEM THROUGH
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE THIRTY LINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING HANNAH BAGHDAD WITH THE
CAL STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FINE. EIGHTEEN WISEMAN CHAIR
MEMBERS MAKE ALEXANDER
RODRIGUEZ ON THE AFTER THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION INSTRUCTORS
FOR THANK YOU BYE TWENTY SIX.
THE MORNING ARMAND EUROPE THERE
START THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
TO CHECK A BOX IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M- ONE
NINETEEN. GOOD MORNING BEGAN
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE AND THIS IS
JAM PACKED WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF PATEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND. TWENTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GENESIS
GONZALEZ AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF THE
TENET GOVERNOR'S ISLAND ECHO
MARKETS THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
THE CHRONICLE SPONSORED EIGHTY
TO PROVIDE AND EFFECTIVELY
AFTER YOUR IDOL TODAY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. PINE. TWENTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACK GOOD
FOR THE INCOMING BUYS FOR THE
LUXURY BRIDGE THE STATE BENEFIT
OFFERINGS FROM QUOTE IS
REPRESENTING TO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS AND ACCESSIBLE
HE HAS TAKEN EXTENSIVE HIGH
SUPPORT ON EIGHTY TWO FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SEE.
FIVE THIRTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM MEMBERS RON RAPP SPEAKING
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THAT
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR BEFORE
WE MOVED TO OPPOSITION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YES WE ARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION WE
WILL LOOK TO ROOM HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE MYSTERON
ORDER CAN YOU QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE. FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THERE IS NO ONE WHO
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK VERY GOOD THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR PAM. I THANK YOU AND A
SUMMER TO APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THIS BILL FOR IT INSTANTLY VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE INTENT OF
THE BILL AND THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL. I DID I DID JUST HAVE A
BRIEF QUESTION DOES IT- AND-
SINCE I WAS LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE DOCUMENTS AND SO FORTH- WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE. SO THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT THE CHANGE IN
NAME ON TRANSCRIPTS MOVING
FORWARD AGAIN I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE IT- STRAIGHT
FORWARD AND SIMPLE FOR PEOPLE
TO DO THAT WHO- TRANS AND- AND
TO REFLECT THEIR IDENTITY- THE
ONE. THE AREA OF CONCERN I.
HAVE AND MAYBE IT'S ALREADY
BEN ADDRESSED IS THAT. THESE
TRANSCRIPTS ARE ALSO USED TO
OFFER THINGS LIKE LICENSING AND
SO FORTH AND SO I UNDERSTAND
SOMEONE WHO'S TRANSGENDER. BUT
DOES THIS BILL ALLOW SOMEONE
WHO ISN'T THAT LET'S SAY JUST
CHANGING FROM. PHYSICAL WE
DON'T WANT IS SOMEONE CHANGE
GOING BACK CHANGING A
TRANSCRIPT TO ACTUALLY MAY BE
THE SAME GENDER AND GENDER
NAMES BUT THE PURPOSE OF. FRAUD
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO TRY TO
LET'S SAY INAPPROPRIATELY
SECURE A LICENSE AND USE THAT
AS EVIDENCE THAT DAY GRADUATED
FROM. A CERTAIN SCHOOL OR
SOMETHING AND SO THE HACK
SOMEONE'S NAME FIND IT FIND A
WAY TO CHANGE THEIR NAME AND
THEN SAY HERE HERE'S MY
TRANSCRIPT I GRADUATE FROM THIS
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL LABOR AND-
PLEASE GIVE ME OF LICENSE SO. I
JUST WANT TO MS OF SECURITY IT
IS THE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
BILL DOES THIS BILL ACTUALLY
RESTRICT THE NAME CHANGE TO
PEOPLE CHANGE WHO WHO- TRANS
GENDER. OR GENDER IDENTITY
DIFFERENT VERSES- SOMEONE WHO
JUST SIMPLY WANT TO CHANGE THE
NAME AND READ. CHANGE THE NAME
OF YOUR TRANSCRIPTS- AND- I
REALIZE THAT ALSO BY THE WAY A
LOT OF PEOPLE DO CHANGE NAMES.
OTHER REASONS AS WELL SO. I
HAVE TO ADMIT IS THE FOR TIME
I'VE BEEN. THAT QUESTION- I
THINK TALKING BY TWO SEPARATE
THINGS ABI- TALKING ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO CHANGE
THEIR NAME FROM A FORMER DEBT
NAME. SO ASSUMING THEY ARE THAT
INDIVIDUAL THERE IS NO EXAMPLE
OF FRAUD I SUSPECT WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. NO OBVIOUSLY
FRAUD IS ON OUR MINDS BECAUSE
WE'RE SEEING THAT A LOT OF
CONTACTS AND- IN IF SOMEONE
WERE TO TRY TO IMPERSONATE
ANOTHER COLLEGE STUDENT AND GET
A TRANSCRIPT. IN MY MIND THAT
IS A DIFFERENT SET OF ISSUES
AND WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE HERE-
PROBABLY A DIFFERENCE OF THE
BILL'S DIFFERENT SORT OF
POLICIES. I'M ASSUMING THAT OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES. HAVE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN BUT HAPPY TO ASK MORE
ABOUT WHAT THE STATE COURTS ARE
TO ENSURE THAT- THAT SOMEONE
CAN'T COME IN PERSON BECAUSE I
SUSPECT THAT- IF THAT CAN
HAPPEN. WHEN THE SITUATION CAN
HAPPEN IN MANY SITUATIONS SOME
COULD SAY- YOU KNOW I'M RICHARD
PAN I GRADUATED FROM THIS
UNIVERSITY EVEN THOUGH I'M NOT
RICHARD PAN. SO I'M HAPPY TO
LOOK INTO THAT BUT I DO SUSPECT
IT'S A IT'S A BROADER ISSUE
THAN WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE.
CORRECT AND NOTIFY IT'S THE
SENATE PLAN IF I MAY. IF THE
BILL GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE IS
HEADED TO JUDICIARY WHICH I
THINK MIGHT BE THEIR PURVIEW
AND THEY MAY HAVE SOME. ANSWERS
FOR YOU THERE HE WAS UNDERGOING
ON THAT. SO I GUESS. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND YES
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHANGE
SO THAT THEIR DAD NAME DOESN'T
SHOW UP ON THE TRANSCRIPT. I
FULLY AGREE WITH THAT IN FACT-
WHAT WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. I JUST WANT TO. BE SURE
WE LOOK AT THIS OTHER ISSUE- TO
BE STRIPPED AND JUST. SO SURE
THAT WHAT WERE. THE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL WHICH INVOLVES
CHANGING NAMES. IS THAT IT
WOULD PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
SECURITY SO THAT WE DON'T
CREATE AN OPENING FOR- THE
PERSON ATION ARE FRIED SO. IN
TERMS OF LIKE THE DOCUMENTATION
WHAT DOCUMENTATION YOU TO
PROVIDE NOR TO CHANGE THE NAME
AT CETERA- SO. CERTAINLY HOPE
LEAVE THAT CAN BE ADDRESSED
AND- JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- BUT I
JUST WANT TO. BE SURE THAT
WE'RE COVERING. THAT ISSUE I
KNOW THAT'S NOT INTENDED TO
THIS BILL THAT'S NOT PURPOSE OF
THIS- IT'S JUST DOWN JUST WANNA
BE SURE WE CAN. THAT BASED.
SOMETHING YOU AND- SENATE. TO
MOVE BILL TO PRO TIME THANK YOU
WILL CERTAIN. ASK THE VERY. WE
THE PROTECT AREN'T. AROUND THE
IN GENERAL. THANK YOU CENTER
PANTS UNDER GLAZER. THE BILL
OKAY VERY GOOD DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS. OKAY
VERY GOOD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
SUPPRESSION EVANS CONSIDERATION
AN ASTRONAUT THANK YOU. MA'AM
CONSULTANT WITH THE BILL'S
REMEMBER CENTER PAN MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWO FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATOR
LEYVA BY LEVEL AYE OTOBO. AYE
VIRTUAL BOGA HIGH COURTESY.
DELI DELI NOW. GLAZER GLAZER BY
MCGUIRE. PAN AM I. BELIEVE THAT
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU SENATORS HAVE
A GOOD DAY. ALL RIGHT NEXT UP
IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
WITH AB FIVE SEVENTY SIX. WHEN
WE ARE ALL READY. TO GO PLEASE
BEGIN IT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I WANNA BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE. CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
HAS THE HIGHEST POPULATION OF
MILITARY PERSONNEL AND SAN
DIEGO IS HOME TO MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACTIVE DUTY
NAVY AND MARINE CORPS SERVICE
MEMBERS. SERVICE MEMBERS OFTEN
TURN TO CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION OR JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS. IN AN EFFORT TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO MILITARY
MEMBERS COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
OFFERED COURSES HOSTED ON
MILITARY BASES. HOWEVER IN
RECENT YEARS INCREASE SECURITY
SCREENING HAS GREATLY REDUCED
ACCESS TO THESE CLASSES FOR
STUDENTS NOT LIVING ON BASE.
AND AS A RESULT MANY CLASSES
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY CLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC. BECAUSE CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. TO COLLECT APARTMENTS
FOR CLASSES THAT ARE CLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC THIS IS EFFECTIVELY
LIMITED THE COURSE OFFERINGS
AVAILABLE TO SERVICE MEMBERS.
AB FIVE SEVEN SIX WOULD WAIVE
THE OPEN COURSE PROVISIONS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSES
PROVIDED TO ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY PERSONNEL ON MILITARY
BASES. THIS WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS TO INCLUDE
THE UNITS OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS GENERATED
IN THOSE CLASSES. FOR PURPOSES
OF STATE APPORTIONMENT THIS
BILL AIMS TO ENSURE MILITARY
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSES. THEY
MAY NOT OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO
ACCESS TO THE WORK SCHEDULES
FAMILY COMMITMENTS AND SERVICE
REQUIREMENTS. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS MARK
MCDONALD WAS SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MISTER
MACDONALD ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES- OKAY YEAH
SORRY THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
THEN DEFINITELY THANK YOU TO-
CENTER MAIENSCHEIN FOR CARING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. MARK
MCDONALD ON THE OPPOSITE FOR
INDIGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THERE ARE BASICALLY
TWO OTHER AREAS- OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSES ARE CLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC- IN STATUTE NAPS ON
K. TWELVE SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND
IN PRISONS AND BOTH OF THOSE
ARE DUE TO SAFETY AND SECURITY
REASONS THIS BILL WOULD
ESSENTIALLY ADD MILITARY BASES
TO THAT LIST- FOR SIMILAR
REASONS AND- AS THE GOOD
SENATOR INDICATED WOULD
PROVIDE. GREATER ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND JOB TRAINING
COURSES FOR OUR MILITARY
PERSONNEL- WHAT RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE NO OTHER LEAD TO SUPPORT
WILL GO HERE TRUE FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NO ONE WE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO
ONE WILL GO TO OUR LINES MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. FIVE SEVENTY
SIX. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND I'M SURE WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE ONE CALLER WHO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT TERRIFIC. WE WILL NOW GO
TO LINE THIRTY TWO. PRIMERICA
ANY WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE PLANNED
CALIFORNIA'S SEVENTY THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I WILL NOW
GO TO LINE. TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GARETH SMYTH WITH THE NAVY
ABOUT HALF OF THE ARMY MARINE
CORPS NAVY AIR FORCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND GRATITUDE TO THE
OFFICE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO
ONE MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB. FIVE
SEVENTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO PRESS
ONE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ADAM CHAIR NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. ALL RIGHT
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DOLLY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR. THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EXCUSE ME BY SENATOR
DOLLY MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL TE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS SENATOR
LEYVA HI. I CHILUBA. HI THE
TROUBLED AYE CORTESE. DELI DELI
I GLAZERS. GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
PAM HI. PAM I. THINK IS A
MEMBER WILL LEAVE THAT BELONG
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MANAGER
MEMBERS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOCAL TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS.
IN THE MEANTIME WE WILL WAIT
PATIENTLY. BERMAN THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU ARE PRESENTING ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU ARE
WELCOME TO **** AND- THE JOYS
OF MOVING FROM ONE COMMITTEE TO
ANOTHER. SO I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE- IT FOR WORKING
WITH ME TO PREPARE THIS BILL
AND WE CERTAINLY ACCEPT ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
SUGGESTED- THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
A STUDENTS TO PETITION FOR
SEATS ON COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. AND CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNING BOARDS I BELIEVE IT'S
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
ANALYSIS IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD HELLO. SAVE YOU
TIME. REDUCE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE- WE HAVE-
TODAY'S STUDENT HERE WHO IS SO
ONE OF THE ADVOCATES FOR THIS
BILL- AS A WITNESS TO TESTIFY
VERY GOOD I THINK I HAVE IN
LEAD SUPPORT AS ACREE PATTERSON
AND A MACHEL ALAS ARE EITHER OF
THEM ON THE LINE. YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL GO
IF THEY DO CALL IN- PLEASE LET
ME KNOW LET THEM SPEAK WELL WE
WILL GO TO ANY SUPPORT HERE IN
THE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
SEEING NO ONE. WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO ONE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATED TO HAVE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR WHO WISHES TO SPEAK. WE DO
WE'RE GONNA GO TO WINE TWENTY
EIGHT ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARLOS MACHADO WITH CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION HE SB
IS CURRENTLY IN A POSITION OF
SUPPORT AMENDED I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE MANAGE RELATED
TO COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS I WILL
BE LEAVING MOMENTS WITH OUR
MEMBERS AND RECOMMEND AN UP
DATE TO OPPOSITION SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR WE DO HAVE ONE
OTHER PERSON WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK FOR
PROCESSING THEM THROUGH RIGHT
NOW VERY GOOD. JUST A MOMENT.
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. PARDON
ME JUST A MOMENT. JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT. PINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MMBERS MY
NAME IS DIRECTLY FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I BELIEVE THAT ARE ONE OF
YOUR LEAD WITNESSES JUST POPPED
IN ON THE LINE MR SECRETARY-
SIN ARE YOU THERE. THANK YOU I
AM APOLOGIES FOR THE MISSED
CONNECTION. NOT A WORRY YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES A WOMAN AT ALL.
PLEASE REPEAT. PERFECT- MY NAME
IS ZACHARY PATTERSON AND I
SERVED AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
IN THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND AS THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ASSOCIATION SENATE BILL EIGHT
TO FOUR WOULD WORK TO EXPAND
THE EXISTENCE OF STUDENT BOARD
MEMBERS TO COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNING BOARDS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS
SERVING IN OVER ONE HUNDRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE STUDENTS SERVING
ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION. ESSENTIALLY
STUDENT REPRESENTATION IS
GROWING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MEANINGFULLY
CHANGING THE MECHANISMS THAT
OPERATE OUR SCHOOL BOARDS
MEANINGFUL STUDENT
REPRESENTATION IS ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE ACCURATE AND HAS SHOWN
MAJOR PROGRESS IN PUSHING
FORWARD THE CRITICAL NEEDS OF
STUDENTS SITTING BOARD MEMBERS
HAVE PASSED CURRICULUM
PERFORMED ATKINS CODES
INTRODUCED RESOLUTIONS OF
SUPPORT AND PARTICIPATED TO THE
SAME EXTENT AS ANY OTHER BOARD
MEMBER. THANKS TO THE PASSAGE
OF BILLS LIKE CHAIRWOMAN LABELS
SB FIVE THREE TWO WE HAVE
LEGITIMIZED THE STUDENTS ARE
COMPETENT AND READY TO CONFRONT
THE PRESSING ISSUES THAT OUR
SCHOOL BOARD SPACE NOW IT'S
TIME THAT WE UNITE THOSE GAPS
IN GOVERNANCE BETWEEN OUR
DISTRICT AND STATE LEVEL BY
ENSURING STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS
THAT ARE COUNTY AND CHARTER
LEVEL EXAMS EVERY STUDENT
DESERVES THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
OF REPRESENTATION AND A
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ASSOCIATION STANDS WITH
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE IN
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE JUST
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW GOING
TO GO TO LEAD OPPOSITION AND I
BELIEVE LEAD OPPOSITION IS
ALICE KESSLER. MS KESTLER ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES I'M CAN
YOU ME WE CAN PLEASE PROCEDURE
OF TWO MINUTES. OKAY WONDERFUL-
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF.
MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORED SPONSORS REGRETTABLY
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR UNLESS IT IS
FURTHER AMENDED. AND I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT WE SUPPORT WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE GOAL OF
THE BILL WHICH IS TO AFFORD IT
AND GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE GOVERNANCE OF
THEIR SCHOOL. AND IN FACT MANY
CHARTER SCHOOLS REPORT THAT
THEY HAVE EXISTING PROCESS USED
IN PLACE TO ENSURE STUDENTS
HAVE MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION
IN SCHOOL GOVERNANCE- HOWEVER
CHARTER SHOOLS ARE UNIQUE AND-
AT NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION AND
ARE SUBJECT TO SOME DIFFERENT
LAWS SUCH AS THE CORPORATIONS
CODE. IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
GOVERNANCE AND OPERATION. AND
AS SUCH WE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHOR FIRST
THE MODIFICATIONS TO THE BILL
TO MAKE IT WORKABLE AND
EFFECTIVE. WITH REGARD TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS. OF PARA CAN TO
CEASE. IS A SUGGEST AMENDMENT
WE MADE IT CLEAR THAT YOU DO OF
A- WORKMAN. DOES NOT. A
MATERIAL REVIEW OF THE CHARTER
UNDER THE CHARTER SCHOOL BOX OF
MATERIAL REVISION TO A SCHOOL
CHARTER MUST BE SUBMITTED AND
APPROVED BY THE CHARTER SCHOOL
AUTHORIZER. THIS IS A PROCESS
THAT MAY TAKE AN EXTENSIVE
AMOUNT OF TIME AND IT SOMETIMES
BECAUSE FOR VOCAL BUTTE.
THEREFORE WE FEEL CLARITY IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW LAW
DOES NOT REQUIRE SCHOOL
JUDICIARY THE FORMAL MATERIAL
REVISION PROCESS. ABSENCES
CLARITY STUDENT PARTICIPATION
COULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED
OR EVEN WORSE IF AN OPERATOR-FAILS TO RESPOND TO THE
MATERIAL REVISION. IN
PARTICIPATION WOULD BE
SUSPENDED NEITHER OF THESE
OUTCOMES WOULD FURTHER THE
INTENT OF THE STEALTH SO
THEREFORE WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THAT YOU ONLY
APPROVED THE MEASURE WHICH
AMENDMENTS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
TECHNICAL ACCURACY. AND
EFFECTIVE APPLICATION OF THIS
NEW PROCESS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR IN HOPES OF. ADDRESSING
OUR REMAINING CONCERNS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
KESTLER REVIEWED FREESHEET YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- OH THREE. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB. EIGHT TWENTY FOUR PLEASE.
FOR ANY WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
THE- PLEASE PRAY. ONE ZERO. NO
ONE IS SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK VERY GOOD THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR DOLLY AND THEN CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WELCOME NICE TO MEET YOU- I
LIKE YOUR BILL I JUST WAS
WONDERING THOUGH I DO HAVE.
SOME CONCERNS ARE YOU ARE YOU
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS TO TRY TO
GET THERE A SUPPORT I KNOW THAT
THEIR- AMENDMENTS SEEM TO BE.
SOMEWHAT SIMPLE. RIGHT I
CERTAINLY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS I
DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT. THE
COMMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF HAS WORKED WITH US AND
WE'VE BEEN AWARE OF THIS-
PARTICULAR CONCERN WE BELIEVE
WE HAVE ADDRESSED IT- THEN I
HOPE THAT THIS IS SIMPLY A
MISUNDERSTANDING. A NUMBER ONE
WE'VE EMPHASIZED THAT THE-
STUDENT AS A NON VOTING MEMBER-
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM THE-
THE LEGISLATION THAT- REQUIRES
THAT OF THESE ENTITIES NON
PROFIT ENTITIES NOT HAVE NON
VOTING- MAY NOT ELECTED
MEMBERSHIP HIM VOTING. ALSO
SPECIFICALLY- WE BELIEVE THE
BILL IS NOT A MATERIAL
REVISION- TO- THE CHARTER
SCHOOL AMENDMENT- THE BILL ONLY
REQUIRES THAT THE STUDENT
MEMBERS LISTED AS PART OF THE
CHARTER DURING THE NEXT CHARTER
RENEWAL. AND THIS BILL STATES
THAT- TO INCLUDE AT THE NEXT
CHARTER RENEWAL WITH THE
CHARTERING AUTHORITY TO
INCLUSION OF PEOPLE MEMBER AS A
CHANGE TO THE GOVERNING BODY OF
THE- OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL. IN
THE MEANTIME ALSO CHARTER
SCHOOL HAS TO DO IS PROVIDE A
WRITTEN NOTICE WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS- TO WHAT'S AUTHORIZERS. SO
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AT
AND MY STAFF WE BELIEVE WE'VE
ADDRESSED THAT CONCERN- BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS AND
HOPES THAT- WHATEVER
MISUNDERSTANDING WE HAVE THEIR-
BUT ARE JUST NOT OUR INTENTION
TO. HAVE THIS REQUEST WHICH I
WOULD POINT OUT CAME FROM
STUDENT BODY ORGANIZATIONS
AROUND- CALIFORNIA AND I WANT
TO RIGHT NOW PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THIS IS
THERE. A LEGISLATION THAT THEY
CAME TO US WITH- AND- THE- I
THINK VERY MUCH BELIEVE IN IN
THIS LEGISLATION SO WE'VE TRIED
TO ADDRESS ALL. THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE NO INTENTION OF TRYING TO
THROW AWAY LEGAL HARD HURDLE-
AT CHARTER SCHOOLS IS A GO FOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
CENTER GLAZER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WELCOME TO THE
WELCOME SENATE YOU'RE ENJOYING
YEARS OF- I- IN GENERAL TERM I
VERY MUCH SUPPORT YOU KNOW
STUDENT REPRESENTATION IN FACT
HAVE A BILL THAT A SECOND
VOTING STUDENT REGENT TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND IT
SERVED AS A TRUSTEE OF THE
STATE UNIVERSITIES WITH THE
STUDENT. TRUSTEE ONE VOTING ONE
NOT THAT WERE PROVIDED
WONDERFUL ENRICHMENT TO OUR
DISCUSSIONS I WAS A LITTLE
CONFUSED AND- AND A COUPLE
PLACES ONE IS I DIDN'T SEE THE
SUIT ORGANIZATIONS LISTED AS
SPONSORS YOU PENSION THEN WHAT
WHAT'S THE ACTUAL FORMAL NAME
OF THE GROUP THAT SPONSORING
THE BILL THEN WELL IT WAS A IT
WAS A VARIETY OF STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAME
TOGETHER CALIFORNIA STUDENT
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION- GENERATION
UP. ARE TWO OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THIS VARIETY
OF OTHER STUDENTS TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT- CAME
TOGETHER- AND APPROACH ME WITH
THIS GENERAL REQUEST TO- HAVE
REPRESENTATION. BUT IT DOES
SEEM AN- ADVOCATE. CAN A SCHOOL
AT STUDENT REPRESENT TODAY.
ABSENT YOUR- I'D THAT THEY CAN
YES OKAY SO- THAT LOCAL CONTROL
EXISTS RIGHT NOW FOR SCHOOL
BOARDS IF THEY WANT TO BRING A
STUDENT. I THINK I GUESS WHAT'S
OF NOTE IN YOURS IS THAT YOU'RE
NOT REALLY GIVING THEM THE
POWER. UNIT SENATE CAN VOTE.
EFFECT EIGHT AS I UNDERSTAND
THE ANALYSIS. THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO CAST A VOTE THAT'S
THE KIND OF CLOAK OF
CONSEQUENTIAL LOADS THAT RIGHT.
THEN AND THAT'S TRUE IN MANY
SITUATIONS WHERE STUDENTS ARE
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD- THEY THEY
HAVE AN ADVISORY VOTE VOTE BUT
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE CONVERSATIONS. YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO PROVIDE STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE- WHICH I THINK
SCHOOL BOARDS MANY SCHOOL
BOARDS FELL INTO. A VERY
VALUABLE AT THE SAME TIME THERE
ARE SOME COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION ACCESS- OR THAT- HAVE
NOT OPEN THEMSELVES UP TO THAT
KIND OF- INPUTTED THAT'S WHAT
TO WHAT TO STUDENTS ARE TRYING
TO ADDRESS IS TO HAVE SOME
MECHANISM TO BE ABLE TO- ASKED
FOR AND OBTAINED A AN ADVISORY
VOTE DOWN TO AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY BE THERE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE
CONVERSATION. WHEN SENSITIVE
TOPICS TO STUDENTS- INTEREST TO
COME UP. WITH THAT THAT RIGHT
WOULD EXIST TODAY UNDER A
PUBLIC HEARING REQUIREMENTS
WOULD NOT. END IN ANY SCHOOL
BOARD THAT THAT. THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE A HAVE A RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE IN TO SHARE THEIR
OPINIONS SIX CERTAINLY THAT
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE- BUT IT
CERTAINLY HAS MORE HEFT AND IT
HAS- A MORE INFORMED MEMBER. IF
IT IS SOMEBODY THAT
CONSISTENTLY SITS AT THE
GOVERNING BODY HEY HEARINGS
HERE'S THE KIND THE OTHER KINDS
OF ISSUES. RATHER THAN SOMEBODY
THAT COMES IN ON ONE PARTICULAR
ISSUE- DOESN'T HAVE ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE BOARD. I THINK
WE- I THINK COMMON SENSE OF
MOST OF THE TIME WOULD INDICATE
THAT. PEOPLE THAT OUR REGULAR
MEMBERS AND ATTEND REGULARLY-
UNDERSTAND. ALL OF THE ISSUES
ARE GOING TO BE MORE OR- LAW-
THAN SOME WHO HAS NOT ABLE TO
BE THERE. IT'S NOT TO ARE SOFT.
AND IF I MAY CENTER AYE WITH
THIS BILLS TO DO YOU WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING IS CORRECT A CAN GO
ATTACK. BUT THIS WOULD HAVE
GIVE THEM THE BILL TO BE ON THE
BOARD AND BE A PART OF OUR
WHICH IS MORE INCLUSIVE THAN
JUST ATTENDING THE MEETING YEAH
AND I DO FIND THAT FAIRLY
COMPELLING TO ME BECAUSE I
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE THAT THAT
BRINGS- BUT CERTAINLY WE WANT
TO BE SURE THAT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WITHIN THEIR OWN NUMBER
THE BORDER NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
ALL THE MATERIALS. AND ACCESS
TO ALL THE MEMBERS- TO BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE AND- BUT I DO THINK
THAT THE- THE SEAT AT THE TABLE
IS A VALUABLE THING. AND I
GUESS SO I'M HAPPY TO LOSE
ABILITY AND MOVE IT FORWARD
THAT INDUSTRY SELLING THEM BUT
I WOULD ALSO JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN ASKING THAT.
EQUIPMENT MISUNDERSTANDING OR
NOT I CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE WORK OUT THESE ISSUES WITH
THE CHARTER SCHOOL COMMUNITY AS
WELL. AND SO I'M HOPING THAT
BEFORE THE ISSUE COMES THE
FLOOR THAT THAT THAT CAN BE
SETTLED AND THEY AND THEY HAVE
A NEW ENJOY MY SUPPORT THEY
HAVE AND WITH THAT SHOT AND
YOU'RE NOT BE TO MOVE THE
PURPOSE ON. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE ANY OF THAT YES IS TRAUB.
GOOD MORE. AS A MEMBER BY-
THINK IT'S MUCH FOR BRING THIS.
THIS FORD. I TO SAY IS A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. AND
SOMEONE WHO WAS PRIVY TO HAVING
ACTUALLY MY DAUGHTER SERVE ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD AS A STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE FOR HER HIGH
SCHOOL- I THINK. THIS IS AN IN
A REALLY. GOOD EFFORT AND
INTENT ON HAVING THAT. I DO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A CONCERN
WITH THE MANDATE PART OF IT-
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE AS-
SENATOR. GLAZER HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER. IT IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO. OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR SCHOOL. BOARD MEMBERS TO
CHOOSE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT-
AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW WITH OUR
STUDENTS BE ABLE TO PETITION.
THE ABILITY TO BE ON THE BOARD
AND BEYOND- NO A MEMBER I
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS ALREADY. ADDED THAT IN
EFFECT. A POSSIBILITY IN OUR IN
OUR IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND I DO SHARE ALSO. SENATOR
DOLLIES ADD CONCERNED WITH
REGARDS TO- THE ISSUE AS FAR AS
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THE
LANGUAGE. SPECIFICALLY STATED
TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THERE
ARE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH THEY FUNCTION. AND I
WOULD HATE TO. YOU KNOW FURTHER
A- A BILL THAT WOULD
INCAPACITATE. THEM FROM- BE
ABLE TO CONDUCT A BET AS IS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE WOULD HAVE TO
WAIT FOR AB. FOR APPROVALS SO
AM I AM GOING TO STAY OFF THIS
BILL RIGHT AT THIS MOMENT-
UNTIL WE HAVE THAT
CLARIFICATION OF THE LANGUAGE
BUT I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING IT IN THE FUTURE-
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING AS
SOMETHING IT WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS BEING. ACCOMMODATED
THERE- IN THAT IT BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR REFORM EXCITED
ABOUT THIS BILL AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO AND HOPEFULLY
SUPPORTING IN THE FUTURE. VERY
GOOD AND BEFORE WE MOVED HERE
CLOSER I WOULD JUST SAY FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. IS IT REQUIRES THE
BOARD TO ACCEPT THE STUDENT
POSITION WITH A PETITION RIGHT
NOW THEY DO NOT HAVE TO ACCEPT
THE POSITION PETITION. SO THIS
BILL WOULD MAKE IT THAT THE
BOARD HAS TO ACCEPT THE
PETITION. SO IT JUST GIVES THE
STUDENTS A LITTLE MORE POWER.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST
LIKE TO ADDRESS TO THE TWO
ISSUES THAT- YOU HAVE- BROUGHT
UP HERE. A NUMBER ONE WITH THE
ISSUE OF MANDATE- I THINK FROM
THE STUDENTS PERSPECTIVE AND
FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE OF
CALIFORNIA. OF THE IDEA THAT WE
ARE IN BRACING OF THE CONCEPT
OF WE WANT TO HEAR FROM THE
STUDENTS WERE AFFECTED BY A
SCHOOL BOARD DECISION. RATHER
THAN IT BEING JUST SIMPLY
OPTIONAL FOR SCHOOL BOARD I
THINK IT WOULD SPEAK- VOLUMES
TO PROTECT THE STUDENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THIS
AND OTHER STUDENTS SHOULD
FOLLOW LIKE YOUR DAUGHTER WHO
HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY- FOR. OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGH
THE SENATE AND THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SIGNATURE OF
THE GOVERNOR- TO SAY THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT ALL
SCHOOL BOARDS- TO INCLUDE. THAT
PARTICULARLY WITH THE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE IN HERE
THAT MAKE SURE IT'S NOT%
INAPPROPRIATE- IT'S A GOOD
ADVISORY VOTE BUT IT INCLUDES
THAT VOICE- THEN I THINK IN
THIS TIME OF DIVISION THAT WE
HAVE- THAT HAVING YOUNGER
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
VALUED. BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS VALUABLE SO I
THOUGHT I WOULD SPEAK TO THAT
IS WHY THE MANDATE AS POSSIBLE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF CULTURES IN IN THE-
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ON COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION ACCESS- AND
SOME OF THOSE ARE NOT AS
WELCOMING OF STUDENTS VOICES AS
OTHERS. AND THEN WITH REGARDS
TO BOTH THE- THE ISSUES RAISED
BY- CENTER DALIAN AND- SENATOR
GLAZERS- I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THE- CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN VERY
PROFESSIONAL AND. AND COLLEGIAL
IN TERMS OF WORKING WITH US- I
THINK WE'VE A MAJOR GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TRY TO WORK WITH THEM.
I'VE BUT THAT STAFF OF YOUR
COMMITTEE HERE THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. HAS ALSO WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS SO- WE HAVE MADE A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT AND- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
PROFESSIONALLY- IN THE HOPES
THAT- WE ADDRESS. WHAT WHATEVER
CONCERNS STILL SEEMS TO REMAIN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK I HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT FROM ASSEMBLY MARK
HUGHES CENTER GLAZER. THANK YOU
CHAIR- THEY THE I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY AMOUNT OF SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. MY GENERAL PRACTICE
IS DAY TO DEFERRED TILL THE
LOCAL. SCHOOL BOARDS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SOME OF BIG LOCAL
CONTROL PERSON. AND I THINK THE
CHALLENGE ON A BILL THAT
MATCHES MY VALUES AND THINGS
THAT I THINK THAT SHOULD BE
DONE IT. TYPICALLY WE- WE WILL.
I SUPPORT MANDATES WHEN WE HAVE
A PROBLEM. WHEN SCHOOL BOARDS
HAVE NOT DONE SOMETHING THAT
THAT IT MATCHES YOU KNOW WHAT I
THINK IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO-
AND IN THIS CASE IT'S A TOTAL
AND CLEAR THAT WE HAVE PROBLEMS
WERE SO THE STUDENTS HAVE
PETITIONED AND THEY'VE THAT
SCHOOL BOARDS A SAID NOW. BUT I
DO RECOGNIZE THE UNIQUE BUT A
PLACE THAT STUDENTS HAVE IN OUR
WORLD. THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
POWER ACCESS TRANSPORTATION IS
THE COMMUNICATION IS A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT. CAN CREATE
IMPEDIMENTS TO REALLY. RAISING
THOSE TYPES OF OBJECTIONS AND I
THINK THOSE ARE STILL
COMPELLING TO ME IN THIS CASE.
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU US SENATOR GLAZERS
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AB. AB
BE EIGHT TWENTY FOUR BY CENTER
GLAZER MATTER CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI- CHILLAGOE. THE
TROUBLED NOT VOTING PARTISI ALL
RIGHT. OR TO THE I. DOLLAR.
DALLI NOT VOTING. GLAZER GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN. THANK YOU SO OF
OUR BELIEF THAT THE CALL FOR
ABSENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MUCH MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR FINAL. OF
THE DAY. I NUMBER TWO. AB FORTY
SIX BY US. MEMBER LOW. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ONCE A WE ARE READY
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES GOOD
MORNING TO SEE AL OF YOU GET
TO SEE MY VERY OWN SENATOR ALSO
FOR THE FIRST TIME PRESENTING.
THAT'S MY WAY OF ELICITING
SUPPORT- THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FORTY SIX WHICH WOULD
SIMPLY EXTEND THE AUTHORIZATION
FOR JOB ORDER CONTRACTING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. I
HAVE JEREMY SMITH ALSO ON THE
LINE I BELIEVE TO HELP ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF WE HAVE LEAD SUPPORT
IN THE FORM OF JEREMY SMITH AND
PAT WHALEN. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
JEREMY SMITH ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. I AM MANAGER. PLEASE
PROCEDURE OF TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU. YOUR BEHALF OF D. STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL BOND COUNSEL IS
THE SPONSOR OF A VEHICLE HE
SAID THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE AS THE-
VEHICLE THIRD ASSEMBLY EXTEND
THE FUNDS ARE RIGHT TALENT.
COLLEGES OKAY TELL JUST YOU
KNOW DOUBLE CONTRACT UNTIL
JANUARY J. FIRST TWENTY SEVEN
ONE TO CHAT LOOK PROJECT OF THE
STATUTE FOR THE REQUIREMENT YOU
JUST GOLDEN TRIANGLE. FROM THE
POWER IT IN TRADES ADVOCATE
BOARD PIECES WATER. THAT
CONSTRUCTION WORK DONE BECAUSE
ATTACKED DOLLARS NOT PROVIDE
MEDICAL WAGES BENEFITS UNDER
THE WAGE BUT I COULD BENEFIT
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE I WOULD
YOU HAVE A PRESS JUGGLING.
INCLUDING PROGRAM. WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR THE EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY SIX MURDERS WHAT DAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NEXT GO TO PAT WHALEN PATH
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I AM GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS GOT
WAYLON ELLIS WILL SNAP BECAUSE
SEE HERE. ON BEHALF OF OUR
CLIENT GUARDIAN GROUP VERY
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX- JOB ORDER CONTRACTING HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO SAVE TIME AND
MONEY. OR JURISDICTIONS ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY- IN IN ALSO
ALL TYPES RETIREMENT PROJECTS.
AS THE INVENTOR OF JOB ORDER
CONTRACTING SEVERAL DECADES AGO
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
JOB ORDER CONTRACTING PROCESS
AND OTHERWISE WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL GO TO ANYONE IN SUPPORT
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR. WITH ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB. EIGHT FORTY SIX. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
MARK MCDONALD MGI ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE SAMPOERNA DINO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
NOT ONLY COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS THE CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE CURRENTLY NOT AMENDED
PETITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MISTER MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WILL GO HERE TRUE FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NO ONE. ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE
MISTER MODERATOR COULD YOU
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX PLEASE. BUT THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE CALLER WHO SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
LINE FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARX AND FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THE HEAVY HANDED
REQUIREMENT FOR A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO USE JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING OBVIATES THE
GAINS THAT YOU MIGHT ACHIEVE
FROM THAT IT SHOULD BE RIVER
FROM WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE. WELL THERE WE GO. MR
MURRAY DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WHO
SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SENATOR TROUBLED DO I
AM. I DO AND I'VE AND I'VE
SPOKEN ON PREVIOUS- COMMITTEES
ON THIS END AND THE FACT THAT I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT IN ORDER TO
HAVE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY- WE
HAVE TO BE OPEN TO EVERYONE
HAVING THAT- YOU KNOW WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT HAVING- EQUITY IN
ACCESS AND TO ME THE ABILITY
FOR ANYONE TO COME IN AND HAVE
THE ABILITY TO A SIMILAR
CONTRACT REPEATING I'M IN A
CONTRACT- FOR ANY PROJECT IS
IMPORTANT. THAT IT TO ME IS THE
ALL AMERICAN DREAM WHEN WE
STOP- WHEN WE START EXCLUDING-
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE THEY CAN
GRADUATE FROM A CERTAIN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
RESURGENT ACADEMY I THINK
THAT'S DISCRIMINATORY AND I
EIGHTY I EAT CHIU LI FEEL I
FEEL FOR THOSE WHO DID NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY OR WHO DID NOT-
I CHOOSE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT-
TO BE BASICALLY DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST THE OPPORTUNITY OF
CONTRACTING AND IN HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES- I TRULY HOPE HARDLY
FEEL THAT THIS IS.
DISCRIMINATORY AND CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL- IN IN IN ITS
INTENT BECAUSE- I DO BELIEVE
THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE-
A PROCESS IN WHICH PEOPLE HAVE
TO GET CERTAIN TYPE OF
EDUCATION AND BE ABLE TO BE
LICENSED PASS THE TEST AND HAVE
A LICENSE IN ORDER TO DO
CERTAIN TYPES OF WORK AND SO
FOR US TO SAY IT BECAUSE YOU
DID NOT GRADUATE FROM THIS
SPECIFIC APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
OR TO SPECIFIC SCHOOL OR
ACADEMY- YOU THEREFORE DO NOT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO WORK
ON THIS PROJECT I FEEL IT IS
ABSOLUTELY WHOLEHEARTEDLY ON
AMERICAN- AND THEREFORE CANNOT
UNFORTUNATELY SUPPORT YOUR BILL
AT THIS TIME BUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR CHAU BOGEY WE
HAVE. ANY OTHER YES SENATOR
GLAZERS. EACH YEAR LEYVA I'M
SUPPORT BILL TODAY- BUT I DO
SHARE THE CONCERN THAT- IF JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING IS A GOOD
THING AND I THINK THAT IT IS. I
THINK THAT WE SHOULDN'T- PUT
LIMITATIONS ON WHO IS ELIGIBLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT- THIS
BILL DOES THAT IN IN CERTAIN
WAYS IN. WHICH THAT IT HADN'T
BUT I THINK THAT THE BROADER.
GOALS THAT YOU HAVE PUT FORWARD
AND YOUR SPONSORS OF THE FORD
OF GOOD ONES FOR BETTER
EFFICIENT. OPERATIONS OF THESE
PROJECTS AND FOR THAT REASON
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
BIG CENTER GLAZER GLAZER
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER CORTESE. CUSHION FOR THE
AUTHOR IF I IF I MAY AND-
WELCOME. GOOD TO SEE YOU- IT'LL
BE- THE SUPPORTING THE BILL OF
COURSE IRRESPECTIVE OF THE FACT
THAT- WE BOTH COME FROM THE
SAME JURISDICTION SO. THANK YOU
THOUGH FOR KNOWLEDGE IN THAT-
IT IS A MEMBER LOW THE QUESTION
I HAVE IS. A BIRD SOME OF THE-
OPPOSITION- COMMENTS- EVEN MADE
BY SOMEBODY- ON THE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THAT
WE'RE GOING IN A CERTAIN
DIRECTION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THIS IS EXISTING LAW AND THE
BILL IS JUST SIMPLY EXTENDING
EXISTING LAW- IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF
THAT EXISTING LAW HAS NOT BEEN
WORKING- I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
AND I JUST. WANTED TO GET THAT
ON THE RECORD. THANK YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD HUMAN
INTEREST THANK CENTER CORTESE
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
TO HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR MCGUIRE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LO FI ASK
PRIVATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB EIGHT FORTY SIX
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA
HI. THEY'VE AYE OTOBO NO WHICH
ABOVE NO CRITICISM- TO THE AYE
DELHI DELHI NOW GLAZER. GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN
RIGHT AND I. THANK YOU THAT A
BILL HELPS- FIVE VOTES AND IT
IS OUT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
LIFT THE CALLS ON BILLS FOR
ANYONE WHO HASN'T BEEN HERE THE
ENTIRE- COMMITTEE MEETING FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVE A GREAT REST OF
THE DAY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CONSENT CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE
CHAIR VOTING ONLINE MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE BY THAT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS CONFIRMED AT SEVEN
VOTES ZERO KNOWS. WE WILL NOW
GO TO ITEM ONE A. B. SIXTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SIXTY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHAIR
VOTING ONLINE VICE CHAIR VOTING
ONLINE COURTESY. CURTIS III
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI THAT BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM TWO AB TWO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO
FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY. CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING HIGH COURT
TESTING CRITICIZED BY MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE BY THAT BILLS SEVEN SIX
TWO ONE SIX TO ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB. FIVE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN SIX. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS. CHIU FORTY
NINE VICE CHAIR VOTING ON A
COURTESY RIGHT COURTESY BY
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO WILL NOTIFY THEM
NINE AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NINE AB EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND. AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON A PER.
CHAIR VOTING ON. OCTOBER BUT
CHAO NOT VOTING. DALY DELI
VOTING MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE I PAN
RIGHT HAND I THE BILL OUT FOR
ZERO. AND I BELIEVE THAT WE THE
ROLE ON A EIGHT FORTIES. I
WOULD TO THANK ALL OF THE
MEMBERS AND EVERYONE WHO. IN PA
TEST TODAY. IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO. TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE
THANK YOU TO WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY AN OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. WE THANK YOU
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
IS ADJOURNED.